[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
I should amend Jonathan's remarks um I'm
more of a budget translator I take stuff
from all these wonks and I try to make
it more understandable so leading expert
I don't know hard to say but anyway I
want to start with Trump's rhetoric on
nuclear weapons some of the less
inflammatory rhetoric just because I
don't want people's blood to boil too
early in the day in an interview with
Reuters a while back he said he wants to
be at the top of the pack on nuclear
weapons
so of course you didn't do his homework
or he would know that United States has
thousands of thousands of nuclear
weapons it's already at the top of the
pack which is a very dubious distinction
obviously and then he said we've fallen
behind on our nuclear capacity again
thousands of nukes a plan to spend a
trillion dollars over three decades
building a new generation of nuclear
weapons again I doubt that he was aware
of this so who knows what he's got in
mind if anybody educates him about this
and then the New START treaty he said oh
just another bad deal that the country
made like the Iran deal and of course
equal numbers is verification you know
we would have liked to go further in
terms of reductions but it certainly is
not an unfair deal but I think Trump's
definition of unfair deal is a deal made
by Barack Obama and so you know we can
take that with a grain of salt but the
next thing as context is the Trump
budget I'm talking about the one for
fiscal 2018 which is going to release in
details shortly and we'll be debating
for the rest of this year and I should
say you know the Pentagon budget is
already running at about six hundred
billion dollars a year which is higher
than the peak of the Reagan buildup it's
more than the next eight countries in
the world combined many of whom are US
allies it's only you know his increase
alone fifty four billion dollars
is about the size of the military budget
of France larger than the budgets of the
United Kingdom Germany Japan and only 12
billion dollars less than the entire
military budget of Russia so anybody who
says Oh Trump's making a small
adjustment you know doesn't know what
they're talking about or they're trying
to pull the wool over your eyes and what
he's planning to do which is a little
different from recent presidencies he
wants to take $1 a billion dollars fifty
four billion dollars out of domestic
programs to match the 54 billion he
wants to put in the military now this is
an outrage but it's also an opportunity
to build coalitions because so many
people are going to be affected he's
going to eliminate 19 agencies and he's
got a the initial hit list of programs
that they were going to get rid of
included the National Endowment of the
Arts
Nessun down with humanities corporation
for public broadcasting legal services
for the poor the u.s. Institute of Peace
Planned Parenthood AmeriCorps the
Appalachian Regional Commission works
works almost entirely in Trump country
so anyway that initial hit list is about
three billion dollars which is one-half
of 1% of the Pentagon budget so it's
peanuts compared to the Pentagon and it
just gives you a sense of how deep
they're going to have to cut on the
domestic side to counterbalance this
proposed build-up and some of the
proposed cuts are just hard to fathom
31% cut of the Environmental Protection
Agency 29% of the State Department this
is the guy who likes to make deals who's
going to make the deals when there's no
State Department they're going to get
rid of eight billion dollars in
low-income block grants of various sorts
pay for low-income heating pay for
housing for the homeless pay for job
training programs that's less than the
cost of one of the twelve ballistic
missile submarines that are part of this
trillion dollar build up and then states
going to be cut twenty nine percent but
UN humanitarian programs will be cut
even deeper so at a time when we have
record refugee crisis we have near
famine in places like South Sudan and
Yemen US support for the UN in those
areas is going to be cut drastically so
there's plenty to debate and plenty to
be outraged about and plenty to fight
back about and so that's the context in
which we'll be debating this nuclear
weapons build-up and I will say the they
just finished up the fiscal 17 budget
because they didn't finish it last year
they let us sort of half done and they
had to figure out what they were going
to do through now in September 30th and
there was some small glimmers of hope
there I mean you got 15 billion dollars
of the 30 billion you wanted for the
military so that's not a good outcome
but many of the programs that he was
trying to get rid of were preserved and
there was an increase in spending for
the National Institute of Health there
was money for famine relief a billion
dollars Planned Parenthood was preserved
so I think just because Trump says it
doesn't mean it's going to happen I
guess that's what I'm saying
and I think we need to fight even harder
against this new budget so you know what
are we getting for our trillion dollars
you know what's this great deal while
the nuclear warhead complex is going to
get 350 billion dollars there's going to
be 12 new submarines for 102 billion
dollars 100 new bombers for a hundred
billion dollars new ICBMs 120 billion
dollars and on and on down the list and
that's without the cost overruns which
we know are going to be dramatic now
some of the companies are going to
benefit include Northrop Grumman and the
bomber general dynamics on the submarine
Lockheed Martin Northrop Grumman Boeing
Raytheon will build on the ICBM and the
cruise missile Honeywell has taken over
Sandia nuclear weapons lab from Lockheed
Martin as of this month there's
companies like Bechtel that Los Alamos
National Laboratories nuclear weapons
lab so if you really want the full story
Susie Snyder's here with Bank on the
bomb if you go to Bank on the bombs
webpage they have a
couple dozen companies involved in
producing nukes details of the contracts
it's a handy little guide of kind of the
Domesday corporations now I don't have a
lot of time left but I'll say two things
one is even at these huge levels of
spending the Pentagon can't afford
everything at once
I'll get the bomber as an example the
Air Force wants to buy the f-35 combat
aircrafts the most expensive weapons
program in history they want to buy a
new tanker they want to buy a new
training aircraft they want to buy new
drones and then they also want to fit in
one hundred billion dollars for a bomber
so there's going to be some fights even
within the military-industrial complex
but whose ox gets gored they're not
going to be rolling in the same
direction and those divisions could work
to our advantage now my final point is
you know a trillion dollars kind of
makes your eyes glaze over
because who who knows what that is but
the future of life Institute has this
fun little tool where you can go
shopping for different things until you
spend your trillion dollars so I went
shopping I hate shopping but I went
shopping and so a hundred million school
lunches is 235 million dollars ten
thousand high school science teachers
five hundred fifty three million dollars
salvage and protect all of our Superfund
sites for a year 681 million dollars
Planned Parenthood for a year five
hundred twenty-eight million dollars
health insurance for a million families
sixteen point eight billion dollars and
homelessness for a year twenty billion
dollars fix all our deficient bridges 71
billion dollars so as I said I hate
shopping so I got kind of exhausted but
that was only ten percent of the
trillion all of those things but there
was another good idea which was burn a 1
million dollar pile of cash every hour
for 30 years
262 billion dollars which is a far
better investment I think you have to
admit than a trillion dollars on nuclear
weapons because we'll be a lot safer as
long as you stay you know away from the
fire so that's mainly what I had to say
I guess the other thing I'll say because
I think I'm probably near the end of my
time is these companies can be beaten on
issues like the f-22 combat aircraft the
b-2 bomber various other programs even
though they pushed they use their
contributions they use the jobs argument
we were able to curtail or cut back very
lucrative programs working with some of
the organizations that helped sponsor
this conference so I don't think we
should just assume that the
military-industrial complex is 10 feet
tall because I think if we get enough
people mobilized we can beat them and I
wouldn't be doing this work if I didn't
believe that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]